le chiffre a tout d'un symbole 0,999
euro le litre de gazole voilà appris que
l'on n'a pas observé depuis longtemps et
bien autant du côté consommateur
l'adition reste trop salée parce que ça
paraissait assez par rapport au prix du
baril donc je crois que il pourrait
encore mieux faire au niveau du fric
j'espère que ça va encore baisser
oui oui c'est prévisible comme ça
descend beaucoup moins vite que ça
augmente forcément
on s'en rend compte c'est quand même un
budget assez important c'est une réalité
les tarifs pratiqués augmente toujours
plus rapidement qu'ils ne baissent
un calcul du aux spéculations des stocks
détenus par les compagnies pétrolières
à titre de rappel quand vous payez votre
litre de gazole 1 euro le litre environ
57 % de la somme a tiré directement dans
la poche de l'état par l'intermédiaire
de la tva et de la tvp
le reste partagé entre distributeurs et
raffineurs et distributeurs qui en
général ne font que 2% de marge pour cet
automobiliste le compte est bon
un retour ou quoi l'étoile ça c'est pour
le comptable c'est plus facile
sachez enfin qu'une fois de plus
internet peut vous aider à trouver la
pompe à la plus attractive et via des
plateformes telles que carbeo.com
zagaz.com ou via le site du ministère
des finances